alright guys we're here with Kaitlyn
long super excited about this
conversation I think you so much for
coming nice to finally meet you
absolutely let's uh let's just go
through your background but I don't want
you to kind of gloss over anything I
want you to actually go through every
step of it so we can really get into
kind of the The Wall Street aspect and
then how you got into crypto but in
crypto since early probably 2013 I
discovered it in 2012 didn't actually
get my first bitcoins until 2013 how to
keep my head down so and the reason is
because I was on Wall Street at that
time I was running a business at Morgan
Stanley and spent 22 years in total on
Wall Street from 94 through 2016 have a
legal background although I've never
practiced law I've been a member the bar
since way back when and then prior to
that grew up in Wyoming which is going
to be relevant I think we're gonna talk
about the Wyoming blockchain bills yeah
so when you get to Wall Street what was
kind of your first job and they walked
me through the different you know part
of the business on Wall Street I worked
in investment banking at Salomon
Brothers doing financial institutions so
just let you know landed there by luck
not a particular interest it's just
that's where I got assigned absolutely
and found financial institutions
incredibly interesting so did a lot of
of work in bank mergers and insurance
company mergers and ended up kind of
steering over towards insurance I find
that a fascinating industry and all of
the 22 years had something to do with
insurance that I worked on Wall Street
why is that so interesting well it's
it's uh it's the law of large numbers
it's it's actually a really math based
industry so and and part of the reason I
didn't practice law is I discovered I
was better at math and words to put it
simply and so that the math has has
always interested me and I don't have a
you know certainly a high level math
background like a cartographer would but
but I knew enough to know and and ended
up running a couple of insurance
companies within Wall Street firms
during those years
very very cool yeah okay and so walk me
through your on Wall Street you know at
that point you'd been there almost 20
years right and what's the first time
somebody tells you about Bitcoin or you
kind of stumble across it and what was
your reaction yeah it was it was the
libertarian community
was free state group I discovered
Austrian economics out of curiosity in
during the 2008 financial crisis I
figured out that the mainstream
explanation of the financial crisis just
didn't make sense and it was a
contradiction that Tim Geithner made on
Charlie Rose's show where he talked
about how interest rates were too low
going into the crisis and he had just
been arguing that interest rates needed
to be lowered still and so obviously
that I thought I just thought it was a
logical and and Doug and at the time
stayed in touch with a lot of hedge fund
friends they were all trying to figure
out figure everything out they'd found
Austrian economics before the financial
crisis in a lot of cases but they dug in
and you know they even pointed me to the
garrison powerpoints that's that's an
obscure Austrian reference that a lot of
folks probably a lot of your listeners
will understand but if you haven't seen
those they are incredible absolutely and
so as you're kind of going into that
rabbit hole and you're discovering all
this stuff you hear about Bitcoin what
its kind of that first reaction oh I
didn't believe it and it was also you
know in those days there was no UI and
and so it was not a technologist my
background and I was intimidated by it
and and just scratched my head and
couldn't believe it like a lot of people
and you start reading and I the reason I
remember it was February 2013 when I
first started to set up what while it is
Jeffrey Tucker sent an email around and
in fact a few months ago I actually
saved that email and I had sent it back
to Jeffrey a few months ago to remind
him of when's the first time he started
writing about Bitcoin it was in an email
from on lacy fare books and I happen to
be flat on my back after having had a
surgery and for a couple days I had time
to really dig into it it takes time and
it takes a lot of repetition and Jeffrey
had some some how-to advice in that
email it was never published on a
website although when I sent it back to
him a couple of months ago he published
it just so he could kind of have a
record of it yeah and so would it
where'd you go to buy a Bitcoin right so
this is 2013 it's pretty early there's
not really that many places where you
know when people are talking about this
stuff and get to kind of what I would
consider a really great
user experience or a user interface so
without the technology background what
do you do yeah that was the there were
eight there was an ATM up at Liberty
forum yes yeah and so yeah that wasn't
actually I very first Bitcoin came from
the blockchain dot info guys they were
up in Liberty Liberty forum explaining
and they they hosted a how to and it was
very well attended by a lot of curious
people and and set up another wallet
through them and and then they sent us
for action you know a few satoshis and
then I went out and put $20 into a
Bitcoin ATM yeah that is amazing story
yeah alright so we go from 2013 to over
the next two three years kind of what is
your relationship with Bitcoin crypto
and I'm assuming you go deeper and
deeper into the rabbit hole get more
excited about it still on Wall Street
still on Wall Street and and and and a
very good friend of mine Ari levy Cohen
who's the one of the cofounders of
singular DTV he was also at Morgan
Stanley at the time and he was he had
gone down the rabbit hole and more so
than I am more technologically savvy
than I was and so you know was already
digging he was already running a full
node I think at that point and so he was
really helpful to me in in understanding
it and there was another the third of
the three Morgan Stanley Musketeers Jake
Dean alt who you probably cross paths
with unfortunately he passed away as you
know but the three of us came from very
different parts of Morgan Stanley and we
connected with each other over Bitcoin I
had known Ari previously but we really
got to know each other more closely it's
like the secret society of crypto on
Wall Street well and there was an
internal Morgan Stanley Bitcoin email
list a forum that got going and what was
fun about it is when I saw ona joined it
they were already probably I don't know
50 people on it and it grew to hundreds
of people this is like teens hasn't it
yeah 2014 and you know everybody
everybody was afraid right a bit of the
compliance Department no one knew what
the implications for being involved with
this would be and so in the beginning I
just lurked and I noticed that most of
the people were younger and more junior
but but but they were off from all over
the place
wasn't that just the technology
department and it wasn't just the United
States it was literally all over the
world a very diverse cross-section of
people who are interested in this and
and it just really blossomed and as I as
it blossomed I started to participate
and then I got a phone call from the
chief technology officer because I was a
managing director running a business and
so you know I had a little gray hair so
to speak and he said come on into my
office and tell me what this is and you
know the board had it turned out just
asked him at the time I think this was
2014 - to make sure that he understood
what this was and didn't miss it because
the hype was starting to form already by
that by that time and I had already been
in several meetings the first first
blockchain company that I met at Morgan
Stanley was Ripple
they came in through a friend and he
pulled me in not knowing I knew anything
about about Bitcoin and I remember about
five minutes into the meeting putting my
pen down and saying oh my god this is
gonna tip and all the Morgan Stanley
people that we were arrayed across the
table from Chris Larson and and Patrick
Griffin the the whole ripple team at the
time there were probably five of them
and then five of us and Morgan Stanley
people looked at me like I was just from
Mars they're like what the heck because
they didn't know anything about what was
what the ripple folks were saying and I
just remember Chris Larson the look on
his face he just he relaxed because he
knew he wasn't fighting an uphill battle
to educate everybody on the other side
of the table and it was just like it the
smile that came across his face when he
found a champion